die ukraine-krise ist eine Tragödie die
man hätte vermeiden
können aber sie ist nun mal entstanden
und alle Parteien müssen hier
schmerzliche Lehren ausziehen im
Wesentlichen geht es hier um den
Ausbruch eines Problems dass ich
aufgestaut hat in der
sicherheitsgeschichte Europas es gibt
komplexe Gründe dafür
China
Urteil immer selbst und entscheidet über
seine Position eigenständig zwischen
Krieg und Frieden Willen wir den Frieden
zwischen Sanktionen und Dialog
entscheiden wir uns für den Dialog
zwischen
die Temperatur absenken sind wir
verletzt aus China hat die Krise nicht
herbeigeführt ist auch keine Partei und
hat keine Waffen
geliefertigen
weshalb um Himmels willen all diese
Vorwürfe und Sanktionen gegen China das
ist überhaupt nicht akzeptabel
als zwei Wochen haben wir unser
Positionspapier zu politischen Beilegung
der Ukraine Krise veröffentlicht hören
mit 12 Vorschlägen es geht um die
Achtung der Souveränität aller Länder
Abkehr von der Mentalität des
kartenkrieges und
Friedensgespräche im Wesentlichen geht
es darum aber bedauerlicherweise wurden
diese Anstrengungen immer wieder
untergraben es scheint Deine unsichtbare
Hand zu geben die den Konflikt
eskalieren will und die Ukraine Krisen
nutzte um bestimmte geopolitische Themen
durchzusetzen
ukraine-krise ist an einem kritischen
Punkt angelangt entweder die
Feindseligkeiten werden eingestellt und
der Frieden wird wieder hergestellt und
eine politische Einigung beginnt oder es
wird mehr Öl ins Feuer gegossen und die
Krise
gerät außer Kontrolle Konflikte
Sanktionen und Druck werden das Problem
nicht lösen wir brauchen Ruhe und
Überlegtheit und Dialog der
Friedensprozess sollte so schnell wie
möglich beginnen und die
legitimensicherheitsinteressen aller
Parteien sollten respektiert werden das
ist der
richtige Weg um dauerhafte Sicherheit in
Europa zu erreichen
oder Bruder
in den Chinesisch amerikanischen
Beziehungen war ja das unbemannte
Flugobjekt
hier handelte es sich um einen Fall
höherer Gewalt und die Fakten sind ganz
klar selbst die USA glaubten nicht dass
das eine physische Bedrohung darstellte
aber im Gegensatz zum internationalen
Völkerrecht und
internationalen sind die USA von einer
schuldvermutung ausgegangen sie haben
überreagiert den Vorfall aufgebaut und
eine diplomatische Krise ausgelöst die
man hätte vermeiden können
ein Zufall kann auch grundlegende Dinge
ans Licht bringen nämlich die erheblich
verzerrte sichte die die USA von China
haben sie betrachten China als Haupt
privat und geopolitischische
Herausforderung es ist so als würde man
den ersten Knopf anhemd falsch zu
knöpfen und insofern hat sich die
amerikanische China-Politik völlig vom
rationalen Pfad abgewegt die USA
behauptete sie will China übertreffen
aber in der Realität
bedeutet der Begriff
wettbewerbung für die USA dass man China
eindämmen und unterdrücken will das ist
aber nur ein Null Summen gespielt
zu erwarten dass China nicht reagiert
wenn es verlortet wird wenn die USA
nicht auf die Bremse tritt sondern
weiter diesen falschen Wege beschreitet
können auch Leitplanken eine Entgleisung
nicht mehr aufhalten und dann wird es
sicher nicht zu Konflikt schon
Konfrontation kommt wer trägt die Folgen
es geht hier wirklich um die
grundlegenden Interessen unserer Völker
und um die Zukunft der Menschheit und
natürlich wendet sich hier dagegen all
das und das ganz entschieden
china hält sich auch weiterhin an die
Prinzipien die präsidentif formuliert
hat nämlich gegenseitige
Achtung friedliche Koexistenz das gilt
auch für unsere Beziehung zu den USA und
wir hoffen dass die amerikanische
Regierung auf die Stimme ihrer Völker
und unsere Völker hörte diese Mentalität
ist Kalten Krieges aufgeht
die politische korrekten ist und wir
hoffen dass die USA ihre Zusagen erfüllt
und mit China
zusammenarbeite und das zum Wohle weiter
und der ganzen Welt